the seed and origin of all the ruin and
various disasters putting in turmoil all
places with unwanted fires we have found
to be this the people of the Huns but
little known from ancient records
dwelling Beyond the maotic Sea near the
icebound ocean exceeding every degree of
savagery the cheeks of the children are
deeply furrowed with the steel from
their very birth in order that the
growth of hair when it appears at the
proper time may be checked by the
wrinkled scars
they grow old without beards and without
any beauty like eunuchs they will have
compact Strong Limbs and thick necks and
are so monstrously ugly and misshapen
that one might take them for two legged
beasts although they have the form of
men however ugly they are so hardy in
their mode of life that they have no
need of fire nor of savory food but eat
the roots of wild plants and the half
raw flesh of any kind of animal
whatsoever which they put between their
thighs and the backs of their horses and
thus warm it a little
they are never protected by any
buildings but they avoid these like
tombs roaming at large amid the
mountains and woods they learned from
the cradle to endure cold hunger and
thirst no one in their country ever
plows a field or touches a plow handle
none of their offspring when asked can
tell you where he comes from since he
was conceived in one place born far from
there and brought up still further away
so when the reports spread widely among
the other Gothic peoples that a race of
men hitherto unknown had now Arisen from
a hidden Nook of the earth like a
tempest of Snows from the high mountains
and was seizing or destroying everything
in its way the greater part of the
people looking for a home removed from
all knowledge of the Savages and after
long deliberation what a boat to choose
they thought that Thrace offered them a
convenient Refuge
but the Goths joined with the Huns and
the halani exceedingly warlike and brave
peoples hardened to the difficulties of
severe toils and set up their camp near
parenthus and reduced to utter ruin the
fertile fields which extended far and
wide about it killing or capturing those
who dwelt there
from there they hastened in Rapid March
took Constantinople greedy for its vast
heaps of treasure Marching In Square
formations for fear of ambushes and
intending to make many mighty efforts to
destroy the famous city but as they went
on their courage was broken when they
beheld The Oblong Circuit of the walls
the blocks of houses covering a vast
space the beauties of the city beyond
their reach the vast population
inhabiting it and the Straits nearby
that separates the pontus from the
Aegean so the Goths destroyed the
factories of warlike materials which
they were preparing and after suffering
greater losses than they had inflicted
they then departed and spread everywhere
over the northern provinces
in war events of importance are the
result of trivial causes so said Julius
Caesar misunderstandings when two
cultures meet for the first time can
quickly turn to battle and so our
sponsor today is War Thunder the most
comprehensive vehicle combat game out
there and won the transports you back in
time to battles from the 1920s to the
present day with a choice of more than 2
000 super detailed tanks planes
helicopters and ships placing you in
frantic player versus player action it's
available on PC Xbox series X and S PS5
and previous generations and whether you
want a super accurate simulation or some
wild fun there were loads of immersion
levels available my personal favorite
part is how customizable the vehicles
are I've been enjoying immersing myself
in the different time periods and the
thousands of different customizations on
offer join me as I crash my favorite
Spitfire again and again and receive a
free bonus pack with a premium account
Vehicles boosters and lots more by
clicking on the link in the description
to War Thunder for supporting history
content on YouTube
a few days later a common man came to
the city from miklau no one had sent him
none of the officials he came of his own
accord he went directly to the Palace of
Montague Zuma and said to him our Lord
and King forgive my boldness I am from
Midtown when I went to the shores of the
great sea there was a mountain range or
small Mountain floating in the midst of
the water and moving here and there
without touching the shore my Lord we
have never seen the like of this
although we guard the coast and are
always on watch
matukuzuma thanked him and said you may
rest now the man who brought the news
had no ears if they had been cut off and
no toes for they had also been cut off
Montague Zuma said take him to the
prison and guard him well then he called
for a priest and appointed him his Grand
Emissary he said to him go to quit
latzlan and tell the official in charge
of the village that it is true strange
things have appeared in the great sea
tell him to investigate these things
himself so as to learn what they may
signify tell him to do this as quickly
as he can and take the Ambassador with
you
when they arrived the envoys spoke with
the official in charge there a man named
pinotel he listened to them with great
attention and then said my lords rest
here with me and send your attendance
out to the shore the attendance went out
and came back in great haste to report
that it was true they had seen two
towers or small mountains floating on
the waves of the sea
the grand Emissary said to penottle I
wish to see these things in person in
order to learn what they are for I must
testify to our Lord as an eyewitness I
will be satisfied with this and will
report to him exactly what I see
therefore he went out to the shore and
they saw what was floating there beyond
the edges of the water they also saw
that seven or eight of the strangers had
left in a small boat and were fishing
with hooks and lines the grand Emissary
climbed up into a broad limbed tree from
there he saw how the strangers were
catching fish and how when they were
done they returned to the ship in their
small boat
they returned as swiftly as possible to
the great city of Tenochtitlan had
reported to motagazuma what they had
observed
our Lord and King it is true that
strange people have come to the shores
of the great sea they were fishing from
a small boat some with rods and others
with a net they fished until late and
then they went back to their two great
towers and climbed up into them there
are about 15 of these people some with
Blue Jackets others with red others with
black or green and still others with
jackets of a soiled color very ugly
they're also a few without jackets on
their heads they wore red handkerchiefs
or Bonnets of a fine scarlet color and
some wore large round hats which must
have been sun shades they have very
light skin much lighter than ours they
all have long beards and their hair only
comes to their ears
Montague Zuma was downcast when he heard
this report
and did not speak a word
in my other account most excellent
Prince I told your majesty of all the
cities and towns which until then had
offered themselves to your Royal Service
and which I held subjugated and
conquered for you I also mentioned that
I had information of a great Lord called
Montezuma of whom the natives of this
country had told me and who lived
according to their computation of
distances about 90 or 100 leagues from
the coast and Port where I had
disembarked and that confiding in the
greatness of God and relying to the
power of your highness's Royal name I
had decided to go and see him wherever
he might be
I even remember that I offered to
accomplish the impossible for I vowed to
your Royal Highness that I would have
him prisoner or dead or subject to the
Royal crown of your majesty
about one thousand of the principal
citizens came out to meet me from the
city and speak to me who all richly
dressed alike according to their fashion
there is a wooden bridge 10 pieces Broad
in the very outskirts of the city across
an opening in the causeway where the
water May flow in and out as it rises
and falls
having passed this bridge we were
received by that Lord Montezuma with
about 200 Chiefs all barefooted and
dressed in a kind of Livery very rich
according to their custom and some more
than others
they approached in two processions near
the walls of the street which is very
Broad and straight and beautiful and
very uniform from one end to the other
being about two-thirds of a league long
and having on both sides very large
houses both Dwelling Places and mosques
Montezuma came in the middle of the
street with two Lords one on the right
side and the other on the left all were
dressed in the same manner except that
Montezuma was short and the other Lords
were Barefoot each supported him below
his arms and as we approached each other
I descended from my horse and was about
to embrace him but the two Lords in
attendance prevented me with their hands
that I might not touch him and they and
he also made the ceremony of kissing the
ground
we went on through the streets until we
came to a large and handsome house which
he had prepared for our reception there
he took me by the hand and led me to a
spacious room in front of the court
where we had entered where he made me
sit on a very rich platform
we have known for a long time from The
Chronicles of our forefathers that
neither I nor those who inhabit this
country are descendants from the
Aborigines of it but from strangers who
came to it from very distant parts and
we also hold that our race was brought
to these parts by a lord whose vassals
they all were and who returned to his
native country and we have always held
that those who descended from him would
come to subjugate this country and us as
his vassals and according to the
direction from which you say you come
which is where the sun rises and from
what you tell us of your great Lord or
King who has sent you here we believe
and hold for certain that he is our
rightful Sovereign especially as you
tell us that since many days he has had
news of us since you are in your
rightful place and in your own homes
rejoice and rest free from all the
trouble of the journey and Wars which
you have had do not believe more than
you see with your own eyes especially
from those who are my enemies and who
are my vassals yet rebelled against me
on your coming as they say in order to
help you I know that they have told you
that I have houses with walls of gold
and that the furniture of my halls and
the other things of my service were also
of gold and that I am or make myself a
God and many other things the houses you
have seen are of lime and stone and
Earth and then he held up his robes and
showing me his body he said to me look
at me and see that I am Flesh and Bones
the same as you and everybody and that I
am mortal and tangible and touching his
arms and body with his hands look how
they have lied to you
I answered all he said certifying that
which seemed to be suitable after this
he took his leave and when he had gone
we were well provided with chickens and
bread and fruits and other necessities
especially such as were required thus I
passed six days well provided with
everything necessary and visited by many
of the Lords six days having passed most
Invincible Prince after I had arrived in
the city of temix Titan and having seen
something of it although little in
proportion to the amount there is to be
seen and noted it appeared to me even
from what I had seen of it and the
country that it would be conducive to
your Royal highnesses Service and to our
security that Montezuma should be in my
power and not at his entire Liberty so
that he might not relax his intention
and disposition to serve your highness
thought this especially because we
Spaniards are somewhat touchy and
importunate and if he should happen to
become angry he could do a such injury
with his great power that they would
remain no recollection of us and so I
determined to seize him and confine him
in my quarters which are very strong I
stationed sufficient guards on the cross
streets and went to the Palace of
Montezuma as I heard at other times gone
to see him and after conversing with him
likely on Pleasant subjects and after he
had given me some valuables in gold and
one of his daughters and some Daughters
of other Lords to some of my companions
I told him that I had learned of what
had happened in the city of nautical or
Al Maria and about the Spaniards whom
they had killed there and that Quail
papoca gave them his excuse that all he
had done had been by Montezuma's order
and that as his vessel he could not have
done otherwise
I said that he ought to send for him and
the other Chiefs who had helped him in
the murder of the Spaniards so that the
truth might be known and they'd be
punished and your majesty might clearly
perceive his good disposition otherwise
the reports of these wicked men might
provoke your highness to anger against
him from which instead of the favors
your highness would Now Grant him evil
would result for I was convinced that
the truth was contrary to what they
declared he immediately sent for certain
of his people to whom he gave a small
Stone figure like a seal which he wore
tied to his arm ordering them to go to
the city of Almeria which is about 60 or
70 leagues from that of muxtidan and
bring the said qualpoka these men
immediately left and after they had gone
I told Montezuma that I was very
grateful to him for the diligence he had
used in the imprisonment of these men
for I must render an account to your
Royal Highness for those murdered
Spaniards to enable me to give this it
now only remains that he should stop in
my quarters until the truth was
established and it was known that he was
blameless
I earnestly prayed him not to feel
pained at this because he would not be
kept a prisoner but would have entire
Liberty well assured that he should
suffer no annoyance or unpleasantness
but rather that in addition to his own
attendance my companions would also obey
his commands
we had much conversation and argument
about this which would be too lengthy to
write as well as little bearing on the
case hence I will not say more than that
he finally agreed to come with me
thus we went to my quarters without
causing any commotion in the city
although some had begun but when
Montezuma heard of it he ordered it to
be stopped and thus all was completely
quiet as though nothing had happened and
this continued all the time I kept
Montezuma prisoner those who had been
sent for qual papoca and the others who
had killed the Spaniards returned
bringing the third qual papoca and one
of his sons and with them 15 other
persons and afterwards they confessed
that they had killed the Spaniards and
so I had them interrogated as to whether
they were vassals of Montezuma
qualpapoka answered asking if there
existed any other Lord of whom he might
be vassal as much as to say there was no
other unlikewise asked them if what had
been done there was by Montezuma's order
and they answered
no when the sentence that they should be
burned was carried into execution all
with one voice said it was true that
Montezuma had ordered them to do it and
that they had obeyed his command
so they were burned publicly in one of
the squares without occasioning any
commotion and the day when they were
burned as soon as they confessed that
Montezuma commanded them to kill the
Spaniards I ordered him to be put in
Chains which frightened him
[Music]
13th of December towards noon we saw a
large high-lying land bearing southeast
of us at about 15 miles distance we
turned our course to the southeast
making straight for this land
we're about two miles off the coast
which showed us a very high double land
but we could not see the Summits of the
mountains owing to the clouds
18th of December at Sunset when it fell
calm we dropped anchor about an hour
after Sunset we saw a number of lights
on Shore and four boats close in Shore
two of which came towards us
the men in the two prowls began to call
out to us in a Rough Hollow Royce but we
could not understand a word of what they
said we however called out to them in
answer upon which they repeated their
cries several times but came no nearer
than a stone shot they also blew several
times on an instrument of which the
sound was like that of a Moorish trumpet
we then ordered one of our Sailors who
had knowledge of trumpet blowing to play
them some tunes in answer those on board
the zhan ordered their second mate who
had come out to India as a Trumpeter to
do the same after this had been repeated
several times on both sides and as it
was getting more and more dark those in
the native prowse had last ceased and
paddled off for more security and to be
on guard against all accidents we
ordered our men to keep double watches
as we are want to do when out at Sea and
to keep in Readiness all necessaries of
War such as muskets Pikes and cutlasses
December the 19th early in the morning a
boat Demand with 13 natives approached
to about a stone's cast from our ships
they cooled out several times but we did
not understand them their speech not
bearing any resemblance to the
vocabulary given us by The Honorable
governor general and councilors of India
as far as we could observe these people
were of ordinary height they had rough
voices and strong Bones the color of
their skin being brown and yellow they
wore Tufts of black hair right upon the
top of their heads tied fast in the
manner of the Japanese at the back of
their heads for clothing as it seemed to
us some of them wore mats others cotton
stuffs almost all of them were naked
from the shoulders to the waist we
repeatedly made signs for them to come
on board with us showing them some white
linen and some knives that formed part
of our cargo they did not come nearer
however but at last paddled back to
shore
in the meantime we convened a council
and resolved to go as near to the shore
as we could since there was good
anchoring around here and these people
apparently sought our friendship
shortly after we had drawn up this
resolution we saw seven more boats put
off from the shore one of which high and
pointed in front manned with 17 natives
paddled round behind the zhan while
another the 13 able-bodied men in her
approached to within half a stone's
throw of our ship the men in these two
boats now then called out to each other
we held up and showed them as before
white linens but they remained where
they were the skipper of the zihan now
sent out to them his quartermaster with
her [ __ ] boat with six paddlers in it
with orders for the second mates that if
these people should offer to come
alongside the zihan they should not
allow too many of them on board of her
but just as the cockpot of the zhan had
put off those in the prowl before us
between the two ships began to paddle so
furiously towards it that when they're
about halfway slightly nearer to our
ship they struck the zhan's [ __ ] boat so
violently alongside with the stem of
their prowl that it got a violent Lurch
upon which the foremost man in this
proud villains with a long blunt Pike
thrust the quartermaster in the neck
several times with so much force that
the poor man fell overboard
upon this the other natives with short
thick clubs and with their paddles fell
upon the men in the [ __ ] boat and
overcame them by main force in which
Frey three of our men were killed and a
fourth got mortally wounded through the
heavy blows
the quartermaster and two Sailors swam
to our ship which they got into alive
after this outrageous and detestable
crime the murderers sent the cockpot
adrift having taken one of the dead
bodies into their prowl and thrown
another into the sea
ourselves and those on board the sea
hands seeing this diligently fired our
muskets and guns and although we did not
hit any of them the two prowls made
haste to the shore where they were Out
Of Reach of shot
we now weighed anchor and set sail since
we could not hope to enter into any
friendly relations with these people or
to be able to get water or Refreshments
here having weighed anchor and being
under sale we saw 22 prowls near the
shore of which 11 swarming with people
were making for our ships we kept quiet
until some of the foremost were Within
Reach of our guns and then fired one or
two shots from The Gun Room without
pieces without however doing them any
harm those on board the zhan also fired
and in the largest prowl hit a man who
held a small white flag in his hand who
fell down as soon as they had got this
volley they paddled back to shore with
great speed they remained lying near the
shore without visiting us any further
seeing that the detestable deed of these
natives against four men of the zhan's
crew perpetrated this morning must teach
us to consider the inhabitants of this
country as enemies
although this land seems to be a very
fine country and we trust that this is
the mainland coast of the unknown South
land
You O King live beyond the confines of
many seas nevertheless impelled by your
humble desire to partake of the benefits
of our civilization you have dispatched
a mission respectfully bearing your
Memorial your Envoy has crossed the Seas
and paid his respects at my court on the
anniversary of my birthday to show your
devotion you have also sent offerings of
your country's produce in consideration
of the fact that your Ambassador and his
Deputy have come a long way with your
Memorial and tribute I have shown them
high favor and have allowed them to be
introduced into my presence as to you're
in treaty to send one of your Nationals
to be accredited to my Celestial court
and to be in control of your country's
trade with China this request is
contrary to all usage of my Dynasty and
cannot possibly be entertained
Europe consists of many other nations
besides your own if each and all
determined to be represented at our
court how could we possibly consent the
thing is utterly impracticable how can
our Dynasty alter its whole procedure
and system of etiquette established for
more than a century in order to meet
your individual views
our Dynasty's Majestic virtue has
penetrated unto every country under
heaven and kings of all Nations have
offered their costly tribute by land and
sea as your Ambassador can see for
himself we possess all things
I set no value on objects strange or
ingenious and I have no use for your
country's manufactures
there was therefore no need to import
the manufacturers of outside Barbarians
in exchange for our own produce but as
the tea silk and porcer then which the
celestial Empire produces are absolute
Necessities to European nations and to
yourselves we have permitted as a signal
Mark of favor that foreign hongs should
be established at Canton
moreover our Dynasty swaying the Myriad
races of the globe extends the same
benevolence towards all
your England is not the only nation
trading at Canton if other nations
following your bad example wrongfully
impotune my ear with further impossible
requests how will it be possible for me
to treat them with easy Indulgence
nevertheless I do not forget the lonely
remoteness of your Island cut off from
the World by intervening wastes of sea
nor do I overlook your excusable
ignorance of the usages of our Celestial
Empire
regarding your nation's worship of the
Lord of Heaven it is the same religion
as the other European nations ever since
the beginning of History Sage Emperors
and Hawaii's rulers have bestowed on
China a moral system and inculcated a
code
there has been no hankering after
heterodox doctrines the distinction
between Chinese and Barbarian is most
strict and your ambassador's request
that barbarians shall be given full
Liberty to disseminate their religion is
utterly unreasonable
it may be O King that the above
proposals have been wantonly made by
your Ambassador on his own
responsibility or you yourself are
ignorant of the dynastic regulations and
had no intention of transgressing them
when you expressed these wild ideas and
hopes and so if after the receipt of
this explicit decree you will likely
give ear to the representations of your
subordinates and allow your Barbarian
Merchants to proceed the ordinances of
the celestial Empire restrict in the
extreme your Merchants will assuredly
never be permitted to land or to reside
there but will be subject to instant
expulsion in that event your Barbarian
merchants
would have had a very long journey for
nothing
do not say that you are not warned in
due time trembling the obey and show no
negligence
[Music]
remember to follow the link in the
description to dive into the chaotic
World of War Thunder and enjoy over 100
Years of vehicles clicking the link will
also give you premium vehicles and
boosters
[Music]